yeah the guys that lost their lives in
the Coliseum just fighting like lines
and they're like are you shooting me
2023 this is what we're getting
but I mean if you're into a Coliseum
tossing some swords and that'd be more
fun so what happened after this is like
uh I guess the Italian government
responded later saying that no we didn't
you know there's nothing on paper
there's nothing I never believed in it
first of all I'll be very clear like and
I think even jail came out I was like
Zuckerberg hit me up I heard that's all
[__] you made that up I'm sure yeah
and then even like all these like rumors
like the Italian government I was like
why would the Italian government trying
to get this because they want the money
obviously no but it's just not the the
government's not going to do that like
no countries I'm like we want it here
it's just like I don't think that's real